welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
fully automated IHC multiplexing
techniques and assay development
presented by dr. mark kelly well
discovery reagent and training lead
companion diagnostics and discovery
broche tissue Diagnostics
my name is execute Ayers and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Roche Diagnostics for more
information about her sponsor please
visit ww-when i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Holly Wong I
will now turn the presentation over to
him so we're going to begin with some
background in utility form multiplexing
and within the research market for
tissue Diagnostics this has been one of
the fastest growing and most popular
areas of interest within research and
that's down to the fact that you can
basically perform multiple detection of
markers on the same section of tissue
and this is particularly useful for
research because in most cases we're
dealing with precious samples we're
looking at panel developments on
multiple markers relating to a
particular disease area or the companion
diagnostic development which may be
researched we can also look at Co
localization into and interaction and in
terms of
those proteins are being expressed and
how they're interacting within with each
cell in terms of the the tissue itself
in also in relation to this we can look
at cell population studies particularly
looking at expression patterns and also
looking at the organization of the tumor
and all of this leading towards an
increased diagnostic and predictive
accuracy and at the moment a lot of the
multiplexing work we're seeing is being
performed within the research sector but
we hope within a few years next few
years we will see this moving forward
towards the hall towards the clinical
space and in turn increasing medical
value for clinical Diagnostics so in
terms of multiplexing and two different
key methods for IAC multiplexing and
that's using fluorescence or chroma
genic detection historically
fluorescence has been the method of
choice because it's easy to see where
there is co-localization of markers
basically where two different
fluorescent markers overlap it creates a
second color in the past for chroma
jhin's with traditional chromatin such
as the a b and red when these do Co
localized it's very difficult to see
where these co-localization events are
occurring however with the introduction
of our new chromosomes which have
translucent properties we can see color
changes so these chromosomes act just
like fluorophores and when they do
overlap it creates a new color which is
a great benefit people that don't have
fluorescent equipment to be able to
detect these particular markers one of
the big advantages for multiplexing as
well is automation and we have automated
platforms which take away the complexity
of the multiplexing assay within this
slide you can see on the top right hand
corner is a manual workflow diagram
which shows all the touch points which
would have to take place to create a
and Manuel iacs a where with
multiplexing
however with automation we take away a
lot of those touch points and provide
full standardization a reduced bench
time and also with the introduction of
ready to use products we can ensure that
we get a high level of reproducibility
across any assays which are developed so
with chromogenic multiplexing which is
the area we're going to focus on
primarily it's really expanded over the
past two to three years with the
introduction of these new chrome regions
and the expansion of the automation that
we can offer within Roche tissue
Diagnostics so at the moment we're
seeing five six different markers on the
same slide and here we've just got a few
examples of what we can offer in terms
of the full fully automated and ready to
use multiplexing detection and as I
mentioned earlier this is all down to
how the new chroma genes work on
conventional chromosomes such as fast
red and fast blue have a very broad
absorbance spectra and this means
they're very difficult to deconvolution
if they overlap it's very difficult to
see at different colors emerging if we
lay over additional chromosomes and
counter stains such as hematoxylin bab
and silver you can see there's such a
broad array of spectra there that it's
going to be very difficult to see
co-localization events the new discovery
chromosomes that we've created a very
much based around HP inkjet printer
where you would have three different
color cartridges which you're able to
create any particular color you like
what by overlapping you can see here
that each of the Discovery chromosomes
discovery yellow purple and teal all
have very narrow absorbance spectra so
when they do overlap it's very different
it's very easy to see where these
co-localization events take place and
also very easy to de convolute using
image analysis tool
so without translucent chromosomes as I
mentioned we do have show the same
properties of fluorescence so basically
we're co-localization takes place we can
see a new color emerging so here we've
got two examples and of the
co-localization staining where we have
discovery purple and discovery yellow
and when they are localized as a jewel
stain it creates this new color which is
a dark red or an orange color so you can
see where those co-localization events
are gonna going to happen another
example here is where we got teal for a
CD one six three and yellow for CD 68
and when they co localize it creates the
green color which you can see in this
image the same two markers CD 1 6 3 CD
68 in purple and teal and when these
co-localize we get this a dark blue or
indigo color showing where the co
localization of events take place and
obviously the huge benefit here is that
you don't need any specialist filters
you don't need a fluorescence scope all
of this can be visualized under
brightfield microscope so let's talk a
little bit about method and assay
development for multiplexing
multiplexing is a complex area there's
no little book in terms of how these
assays are created but with our
experience with the research tissue
research market that we've been working
in we've put together this presentation
which will give you some outlines as to
how to create your multiplex assays so
let's look at some of the methods of
detection so this first method here
we're going to talk about is an anti
species approach where we deposit our
fluorophores or our chromosomes with an
enzyme so the big advantage here is
there isn't really any species
limitations the the way in which the
enzyme enzymatic
the deposition occurs allows us to have
an increased signal intensity greater
stability and much easier to transfer
between a fluorescence on a bright field
procedure downsides here can that can be
that the assets do take a little bit
longer and if you are using certain
floors they can be bleached or they can
be susceptible to any denaturing or
quench steps and this can happen by H 2
or 2 which is quite commonly used within
these types of assets these are a couple
of the detection methods that we have
available for the discovery so this is
an anti species or an t hat an approach
with enzyme deposited chromosomes on the
left hand side we have the multimode
attention which basically is a an anti
species secondary antibody and
conjugated to that is your enzyme which
is going to drive the chromogenic
reaction and in this case it can be
either HR p or AP and on the right hand
side we have a hapten detection method
and here what we use is a proprietary
product created at rush tissue
Diagnostics whereby we conjugated a
hapten or a synthetic label to a
secondary antibody so in this case we
use H Q or NP and then we come in with
an antibody directed against these
synthetic labels so we come in with an
anti h q h RP or an anti NP AP with this
we really see a huge increase in
specificity sensitive sensitivity and
signal intensity and we can use this
method with chromosomes or fluorophores
and these are excellent for detecting
lower expressing targets
so once we've decided on the type of
detection method that we're going to
implement we recommend not diving
straight into a multiplex assay what we
advise is optimizing each antibody
individually so once you've decided on
the panel that you're creating optimize
each of those individually work out
which marker is going to work best with
each detection type with each chromatin
type and then create your staining
reference library so you've always got
something to go back to to in order to
determine if that stain is working
effectively if you were to dive straight
into a four or five plagues I say it's
very difficult to work out what may or
may not have gone wrong with the assay
if there are problems at the end of the
staining run by having that reference
library you can go back and ensure that
everything is working effectively in
each of the different detection methods
one of the biggest issues we find with
multiplexing assays is actually creating
an assay where the different markers are
able to be configured with their
different antigen retrieval methods so
in some cases different markers react
differently to different types of
antigen retrieval and it's important
that we try and find some common ground
so trying to find a retrieval method
which is going to suit all the different
antigens within that particular tissue
section with the software that we have
available for the discovery what we can
offer is progressive retrieval what we
mean by that is basically being able to
add additional retrieval as we go
through the procedure so you may start
off with you're in your first sequence
by staining something which has a very
light antigen retrieval and then towards
the end of the the sequence we've added
or progressively added more retrieval to
hits those additional antigens
throughout the sequences the to kick key
main the two main types of retrieval
that we use or our customers use would
be either heat retrieval or enzymatic
retrieval as I mentioned with with heat
to try and find a method that's
efficient for all the antigens we can
add additional heat applications through
each sequences and then we can also use
different types of retrieval buffer so
in terms of a high or a low pH retrieval
buffer for each of the different markers
enzymatic retrieval can be a little bit
problematic because they can have a
negative effect one of the targets
within the tissue so in this case if you
do have to use an enzyme we always
recommend using that in the final
sequence you're not going to affect any
of the other markers within that
particular
Autoplex assay as I mentioned as well we
we offer either sequential or cocktailed
multiplexing options so with the
sequential method what we do is we
actually apply each antibody and
detection individually and then we move
on to the next sequence and in between
each of these sequences we perform a
denaturing or Ellucian step which avoids
any cross reactivity by breaking down
the initial antibodies which may have
been applied this allows us to use the
same species same enzyme detection so
you may wish as you can see in this
diagram we can use all Manas primary
antibodies and we can also use all HRP
enzymes to drive the current genetic
reactions just by applying those DNA
drink steps in between each sequence
with the cocktailed antibodies you can
see here that we can actually apply to
different species at the same time and
as you can see as well by applying two
different enzymes we can perform up to
four different markers over two
sequences by performing this cocktailed
method this can be a little bit
problematic because you have to ensure
that all your detection so configured
correctly but it can help by reducing
some of the runtime antibody detection
sequence is also key importance as you
can see here we've got two examples of
saying stain but using different types
of detection so it's important to
determine the optimal type of detection
that you're going to be using so on the
left hand side we've got am Ultimo
detection and on the right hand side
we've got a hapten based detection and
you can see the increased sensitivity
and specificity of the hats and
detection is giving them all optimal
signal from that particular at stain so
it's important to ensure using the best
possible detection before you create the
multiplex assay if you plan to use a
silver detection as well it's also
important to be conscious that it can be
affected by hydrogen peroxide treatment
or HRP neutralization and this should be
placed last in the sequence because it
can cause fading to that particular
silver chromium so da B is a traditional
chroma gene used in IAC
and it's a great chromatin but we can
see problems when we're actually using
it within a multiplex assay so here
we're going to talk about something that
we call the umbrella effects of DA B and
D a B we we think inhibits staining of
the markers in close proximity by
basically creating a molecular shell so
what you can see here is if we try and
stay in our marker with da B you can see
it creates the the DA B deposits around
that particular marker and next to it we
have another antibody which is an in
such close proximity and we can come in
and we can stain that effectively to the
left-hand side of the the da B marker
you can see a third and the molecular
shell that we say with the DA B can
actually prevent that particular mark
coming in to bind effectively with the
staining images on this picture as well
what you can see is that just by
alternating the position of the da b
stain we can actually improve the
quality of the staining so on the left
hand side we've used da B as the first
marker
20 and it's very difficult here to see
the CD 30 and silver and just by
swapping these over and putting CD 31st
and CD 22nd you can see that the the
staining is a much more apparent and
just these changes in sequence can have
a big impact on chroma genic
multiplexing so here we really need to
consider consider marker localization
ideally and this isn't always going to
happen and it would be optimal to
consider markers that don't overlap this
is quite difficult in most cases so if
you do need to choose markers that are
are going to overlap it's important to
choose the correct chroma Jones that you
may wish to use so here we can see by
using as ki67 in yellow and cd20 with
purple it's very easy to see where the
co-localization takes place however
below where we have cd8 in purple CD 3
and silver it's very difficult we just
get a almost a black stain and it's very
difficult to see where those two
different markers are so here we have an
example of this chromatin sequence and
changing these to actually create the
best staining outcome at the end of the
sequence so here we have CD a CD 3 and
what we recommend doing is actually
creating a four different slides with
different combinations of firstly the
primary antibody and then secondly the
detection so we start off with CD 3 CD 8
and then in the second set of slides we
swap over the primaries and we use CD 8
followed by CD 3 you can see here just
by swapping the order of the detection
and the primary antibody it really has a
big impact on the type of staining that
you would see with the two images on the
left being no optimal because you can
see the purple you can also see the DEA
be staining so one of the key rules of
thumb that we have seen is we would
suggest always staining the lower
expresso first to give the best possible
or staining I touched on this briefly
earlier sir denaturation and
neutralization and these are methods to
prevent cross reactivity with in a
sequential multiplex staining so an
example would be if you're using two
mouse primary antibodies if you didn't
perform denaturation this is what would
happen what would happen is you would
come in with your first primary antibody
your secondary and then your chroma John
without being a iteration you would
start on your second sequence you'll
come in with another Mouse primary
antibody come in with another anti-mouse
secondary antibody the problem here
would be that without being a duration a
secondary antibody would actually bind
to the previously bound primary antibody
by creating cross reactivity within the
stain as you can see here
neutralization is a way of deactivating
HRP enzymes which would be conjugated to
your secondary antibody so if we want to
perform neutralization we would come in
with the primary secondary conjugated to
HR P we would perform the chroma genic
reaction and then in the second sequence
we would be the same again we would come
in with the primary secondary because
this is also conjugated to HR P any
remaining HR p from the previously bound
complex actually create cross reactivity
within the state but we would see both
Bab and purple staining non-specifically
potentially different sites within the
tissue so how do we go about performing
denaturation and neutralization so we've
got three different methods that we
advise the use of firstly heat
denaturation
which can be used when it's the same
primary antibody species and also when
it's the same HR at the same enzyme
species as well with the same enzyme
type what we found is by performing a
low pH high SDS buffer such as ultra C
t2 at a high heat this actually
deactivates both the immunoglobulin
complexes and also the enzyme that
you're actually using within that
particular assay we can also use acid
denaturation so by using a very low pH
solution such as discovery antibody
denaturing reagent
this can help deactivate and neutralize
any previously bound primary antibodies
within the sequence if you're looking
just to perform HRP neutralization
without any denaturation then you can
also use discovery inhibitor or hydrogen
peroxide to deactivate the HRP
conjugates previously bound
when we do perform being a creation this
is what happens we come in with primary
the second green and the chromium we
apply our high heat and ultra CC - so
that's the low pH high SDS buffer and
what this does is it's going to break
down those previously bound
immunoglobulin popul institutes the
primary and the secondary antibody
meaning when we come in with our next
sequence we have our primary our
secondary and the secondary is only
going to bind to the primary because it
has nothing else to buy - so this means
we're going to get to discrete signals
without any cross reactivity with
neutralization again we come in with our
primary OHRP conjugated secondary
apply our chromium then we apply h2o to
or discovery inhibitor and this is going
to deactivate any remaining HR P's
within the tissue that when we come in
with our second primary antibody green
conjugated HRP again we're just going to
be left with two discrete signals so
with the denaturing or Ellucian methods
that we can offer as i mentioned before
we we tend to recommend the use of a
high heat and a low pH buffer to perform
this type of denaturation but you can do
this in different ways so we have a
chemical solution using the antibody
denaturing reagent which is a very
acidic solution which is it's pretty
useful for when you're using maybe a low
order multiplex but by applying acid
continually to a high order multiplex
this can start to interfere with
morphology across the tissue the second
image is using reaction buffer or a TBS
buffer with high heat and you can see
this also is a
active by performing a combination of
acid and heat you can see that the
actual staining can start to deteriorate
because the antigenicity starts to be
affected by the different types of
dilution methods one way to check your
denaturation efficiency is to run
dropout controls and this basically
means by removing a components at the
assay we can actually check to see
whether the denaturing is working so on
your test protocol you can see we've got
two targets and we're staying in with a
anti-mouse secondary and also an anti
mouse secondary within the second
sequence so here by performing a dropout
control on the second protocol by taking
away the two chromosomes or taking away
the first chromosome and then the second
primary if we see no cross reactivity we
should see no staining if we see any
staining at all then that's telling us
that cross reactivity is taking place
because we shouldn't be able to see any
cross reactivity if the denaturation has
been affected okay so let's move on to
actually how to create a protocol and
throughout all of these methods we
always assume that we've started with a
single stain and we've created a
staining reference so we'll start off
but with a three Plex I say where we
need to consider pretreatment antibody
species marker localization and the
detection types that we're going to be
using so the tissue here that we're
going to use is long and we're going to
be running in with TTFN one so that's
five synonym CD 56 with da be purple and
yellow and based on the single staining
references that we've created we've
decided that we're going to run TTFN one
with da p which is nuclear
snaps fire sin which is cytoplasmic with
yellow and CD 56 staining the main
brain with purple and here we've given
you two examples of optimal and non
optimal staining so on the left hand
side is what we think is a good quality
stain we started off with nuclear
staining with da be followed by the
cytoplasmic staining in yellow and then
finally the the CD 56 with purple on the
right hand side is non optimal and what
we've done here is actually to swap
around the sequence just to show you
what would happen if we were to run da
be last in the sequence and what you can
see here is the da B has almost masked
everything else within that particular
stain so it's really important to be
sure where you're gonna be using your da
B in this case da B is an excellent for
nuclear staining for some of the lower
expressing markers out within a
multiplex so the next one we'll look at
is a four-plex assay in this one we have
a lymph node and we're staining it with
CD 30 CD 20 cd4 cd8 we're going to be
using da be purple teal and silver again
we've assumed that we've optimized using
our single stain references and
therefore we've created the following
initial stain which is CD 13 silver CD 4
in teal CD 8 in purple and CD 20 and da
P and what we've done here is actually
we've created an expression ratio and as
I mentioned before we always recommend
running the lower expressing marker
first
so CD 30 cd4 and cd8 should be an
equivocal in terms of expression ratio
and then CD 20 is going to be the high
expressor and here we've create an
example where we've actually used da B
as the high expresso which isn't always
advisable as you can see from the
staining image and what you can see here
is the CD 20 years almost masking every
other car
within that tissue section you can see a
little bit of the teal but it's really
difficult to see the purple or the
silver coming through within that
particular state so what we're gonna do
here is actually move the cd20 further
down the sequence whereby CD 30 remains
in first position CD 20 in the second
position you can see immediately just by
changing the order of that sequence some
of the other markers now become apparent
so ideally within this particular
example we probably wouldn't use the a B
as our chrome engine of choice just
purely because of the number of markers
of a trying to detect and the way in
which da B can mask of the markers but
we're just using this as a example for
you to see where we actually can move
around the different sequences and this
will actually create a more improved
stain and visualization method another
example here is the use of red and
purple and what we found is that red
actually gets more pink in terms of its
hue if you use in later steps within the
sequence so on the top left image we've
used cd8 with purple cd68 red ki-67 in
yellow and then upon keratin with teal
you can see that the the red staining is
very dark with for the cd68 however if
we were on the right hand side move zd68
to the last part of the sequence the
humors changed completely and is
actually looking a little bit more like
the purple so it's very difficult to
actually notice the contrast between the
two different markers so it's important
to consider where you're actually going
to be using these different chromosomes
within the sequence never example here
where we're using co-localize antigens
of CD 30 and CD 20 the top left is the
optimal staining where we've used CD 30
first CD twenty CD eight and then CD
ki-67 in teal
and you can see that by moving the
different sequences around it actually
really changes the way in which the
staining works so the top right staining
example here we put cd20 first and it
masks everything the bottom left
we've put CD 30 towards the end and it's
very difficult to see that staining at
all and then in the bottom right what
we've done is actually to take Vav out
completely and in this case we're using
a newer chromium discovery green which
we thought may help actually improve the
staining sequence but in this case it's
actually still not optimal the example
here though where we have implemented
Discovery Green in place of the da B is
really showing a big improvement in the
way in which we can actually visualize
these different markers so the two
images to the left we're using CD 20
with da B and you can see we can see
some of those actual markers there but
it's very difficult to make out each of
them discreetly on the right hand side
actually what we've done is to take away
the da B and replace it with green and
by doing that everything becomes a lot
more clear it's much more easy to see
those different markers because the way
in which the green chroma gene works and
allows us to have better contrast
against the other markers that we're
using where we have non localized
antigens we have a much greater
flexibility in terms of the sequence
that we're running in this case because
none of them are Co localized you can
really place the chromosomes in any
particular order so here we've got C D
68 s in the first position CD 18 second
on the left hand side and then on the
right hand side we've alternated these
and you can see there's not a great deal
of difference between the staining
patterns and this is really an important
aspect to consider to ensure that the
way in which you're looking at these
markers and the way in which you're
applying the different chromosomes to
get the best
while staining so to summarize these
detection tips that we've met mentioned
and this is a recommended chromatin
sequence that we've put together and as
you can see silver really can be
inserted anywhere within the sequence
but it's really dependent on the type of
neutralization methods you may be using
if you are using h2o to neutralization
then it's important to use this right at
the end of the sequence also consider
the masking effects of da be
particularly incur localized markers and
how da B could interfere with the
staining of these different markers
within the tissue
Redwing found does get more pink if it's
used in later steps within the sequence
and you definitely get a better contrast
between the red and purple if it's
applied early in the sequence
particularly before yellow and teal as I
mentioned with silver it's important to
use it at the end of the sequence if you
are using neutralization and also teal
we found just fade a little bit if it's
a prolonged exposure to h2o too but
those are a couple of tips to consider
so I also want to touch upon some of the
fluorescent options that we have
available for the discovery ultra as
well around to two and a half years ago
we launched the discovery five Plex
immunofluorescence procedure and with
the if' procedure what this offers is a
more robust pre-optimized procedure
whereby the customer can come in with
their primary antibodies and just excuse
me apply these primary antibodies and
we've already preset the detection order
and with the the neutralization on
denaturing steps pre-applied so this is
a lot more easy to use by applying the
ready-to-use products that we have
available the customers have pretty much
a plug-and-play option available to them
to create a fluorescent five Plex I say
these are what the HRP fluorophores that
we use look like all of these are two
ramai driven floors and we have
rhodamine 6g DCC red 610 Pham and cy5
one of the big benefits we found with
our products and by using the software
that we provide is ability to switch
easily between bright field and
fluorescents without the real need to
reoptimize so for example you could
could optimize your cd3 or cd8 antibody
with da B and instead of pre optimizing
for fluorescence you can simply deselect
da be within your protocol and then
reselect one of fluorescent markers and
you'll get equivocal staining within
your tissue and then within the five
flex you can build upon these options to
create up to five different markers on
the same slide so here we have Fox p3
with discovery firm we have cd68 in CY 5
cd8 with
discovery read 610 CD three with DCC at
CD 20 with rhodamine 6g and that's were
to give you your five different markers
and this is created with the five flex
procedure what you can also do is
actually to utilize the universal
procedure within the disc of reel to
software if you are looking for greater
flexibility if that the the five flex
procedure doesn't offer you everything
that you require so in terms of
multiplexing where are we heading one of
the big demands that we're seeing from
the clinic and also from farmer is the
increased demand on multiplexed panels
or pre-optimized fully automated
multiplex panels specifically
disease-focused
such as immuno oncology and we're also
seeing a big pull from the chromogenic
side as well as the if' side another
demand that we're seeing as well as the
use of multiple single copy mrna stains
as well the ability to detect multiple
RNA or DNA targets in the same tissue
and potentially adding protein targets
with that as well it's becoming very
popular as well so an example here
within the image is a duplex mrna stain
along with a duplex IHC as well one of
the products we're also working on is
the ability to detect proximal events
within the tissue so an example here is
the ability to see where pd-1 and PDL
one is interacting not Co localizing but
interacting so where we see proximal
event so within 40 nanometers that is
when we see staining if these two
markers are not in proximity then we
don't see any staining and the examples
that we have here on the right hand side
is where you can see the PD 1b
interactions in purple we can see the
non proximal events of the PD one in
yellow and then we've also stained it
with two additional markers as well at
cd8 and CP 68 with IHC and so this gives
a real different type of me multiplex I
see with by providing a high level of
information from the particular state
but also this could be combined with
other targets as well such as mRNA and
finally in summary and with the
increased demand in multiplexing what
we're trying to do for our customers is
really increase the number of tools
available what we're seeing is as the
demand on the number of markers
increases obviously in complexity also
increases so it's really important to
choose the best method for your
application in some cases if' may be the
best method in some cases brightfield
may be the best method but it's
important to look at all your markers
individually to actually consider the
type the localization expression levels
and then alternate detection to
determine the best fit as we saw in some
of the examples it's very important to
utilize the ability to use the sequence
sequences within the software to create
the best possible staining combinations
and as I mentioned earlier as well there
isn't really a rulebook at the moment
for multiplexing we've got a lot of
experience in this field and by working
closely with our customers we've tried
to give the best possible guidance for
creating these types of assays they're
not easy assays but they can create
something which is going to provide a
high level of information for research
and hopefully within the clinic and also
allow that increase medical value within
the future I'd like to thank you for
your time and as say the omission
mentioned I'd be happy to answer any
questions that come in via email
thank you dr. Ellie
for that informative presentation I
would also like to thank our sponsor
Roche Diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible and before
we go I want to let everyone know that
this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
and as a final reminder any questions
submitted will be followed up with via
email by our speaker that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye